tourne énormément en province et qu'une
maison de 150 mètres carrés compte et
dans certaines régions de province ça
vaut le prix dans l'appartement
justement la manette humanoïdes
c'est vrai j'ai fait le tour vous allez
me dire le nombre de mètres carrés jim
orrell à [ __ ] castaldi ce qui fait
l'addition de toutes ces résidents
autour de 250 alors t'as qu'à toi y'a
pas de locaux quatre enfants ils sont
champions du bas ventre
vous n'êtes pas prêt avec locataires oui
mais bon quand même plus propriétaire de
150 m² beinheim 70 mètres carrés
soixante dix mois à venir vérifier quand
vous avez vu toi carrese oui attention
nicolas pernikoff 173 maintenant je suis
en province imité au web it hot et en
banlieue parisienne et l'émulation m de
paris nommé my way you lie
n'hésitez pas avec légal france télé
alors jours pour une petite question
d'ailleurs s'en sont remis plus la
piscine c'est bon quatre piscines
abidjan depuis l'année avec piscine non
ces gens et voir quelles pistes et
combien vous avez dit le mètre carré
chez ô5 c'est noir pourra jamais s'en
remettre car et c'est bon
ouais sympa remake est très bon c'est 80
81 tout seul c'est quand même j la plus
notre carré comme moi oui n'empêche ils
tous même s'il vise il le maîtrise
non mais c'est vrai non mais parce qu'on
fait à verser la pâte au président même
le premier point il est à 150 m isabelle
125 m² pour av
c'est beau c'est pas la peine d'en
rajouter vous savez moi ce que je fais
je vois le nombre de mètres carrés jeu à
part le prix au mètre carré de l'endroit
où vous êtes et je vois combien coûte
cette maison d'accord une façon ça met
complètement d'évaluer parce qu'il nous
colle deux immeubles à côté de chou
rouge
ça c'est la tueuse légal surtout pas
bien sûr parce que ce soit imminent
après le le la le centre aéré aussi on
passe à clore le coeur tu veux y aller
mais ma belle tu vas entendre l'hymne ô
ma 16h sortira je peux dire que pour le
coup de prendre leur vélo choco bn en
battant bastia fneeq tu vas dire que tu
vas voir tu vas voir et avec ton mari
toi oui et de chats ça le problème c'est
que jamais lui faire faire le vendredi
on la tient plus montiel alors ça dépend
de quel point de telles propriétés vous
parlez
mais comment ils se la pètent pochette à
combien de propriété alors je loue à
paris et j'ai une maison au pyla sur mer
ah oui c'est la vérité je dis toujours
la vérité alors à paris j'ai 172 mètres
carrés je vis seule je vous emmerde et
mais c'est sa vie c'est les chambres de
bonnes réunis c'est super sympa une très
belle entrée des très belles oeuvres
d'art ils se croient qu'on va je sois
pas pour la forêt non il est sympa
l'appart et je vois la tour eiffel
c'était mon rêve de provincial et au
pyla escrocs jenine territoires n'est ce
pas
[Applaudissements]
jolie maison au pyla d'ailleurs que jean
edouard connais je connais pas ce que
j'avais tourné pour section la tournée
cette chaire de recherche succès 1-0 et
juste l'apéro et j'ai fait un grand
dîner chez moi voilà away et toute
l'équipe de tournage mais je n'ai dit
que tu la vends des mets ta mère ait toi
on te demande toujours la maison
toujours y toucher pour l'instant 75 m²
à deux c'est bien et on va bientôt
déménager parce que c'est trop petit en
attendant sa politique par des films
dont un enfant
non pas du tout mais beaucoup bout d'un
moment voilà des vêtements légers
complètement fou séjour va prendre
l'apéro mais sérieux 64 et son mec et
des gens et béate 64 m² et bim assistant
mais j'y vois là ces gens là mais
delphine vous les lirez complètement la
crise et qu'ils deviennent fous et touré
environ 200 mais toi tu te salue les
rites et un problème problème
kate je te donnerai vérité il ya des
gens dont je sais pas qui est cette
femme l'a vérifié regarda pas l'air très
clair mon rituel de sièges et le werder
n'a envoyé 200 m² environ
tout fan des propriétaires tous
créateurs propriétaires n'ont jamais eu
a dit marie mandy moore est ce que tu as
fait émerger les messieurs les cheveux
mais plusieurs appartements m qu'est ce
qui dit il
je vous hais